on the long and winding dirt paths of
the toughest off-road race in the world
he is mr. Dakar Stephan Pitta ansel has
won the rally a dozen times already
he and his co-pilot know how to get
ahead and stay ahead but there is the
nine-time World Rally Champion after
starting three minutes back on the
penultimate stage and nearly six minutes
back overall Sebastien Loeb and his
copilot were gyrating and bouncing over
the course making up huge chunks of time
and catching up has paid the on-cell all
but flew through the dust and sand of
western Argentina he and his Pujo
teammate came that close
betta Unseld kept trying to stay ahead
but couldn't stop live from beating him
in the stage by 18 seconds on the 750
kilometer day still that was far from
enough to change the standings betta
Ansel still has a five and a half minute
overall lead mr. Dakar will bask in the
glory of the 12th and final stage a
short 61 kilometer
team Pujo is set to go one two and three
in the final standings